so by getting to know this super
versatile little feature in 3.js you can
be creating all sorts of really useful
effects like gunshot blasts footsteps
all with relatively little work which is
cool i like it when you get big rewards
for little effort so today we're going
to be fiddling around with 3.js decal
system and i'll walk you through how
easy it is to set up and use and the
general idea is to have something that's
almost like a directional light so you
have this 3d box that forms a
directional volume and that directional
volume is projected onto the mesh that
you want to apply the decal to but
instead of computing lighting values
like you would for a directional light
you're projecting this texture instead
and basically what you'll do is you'll
cut away any part of the mesh that isn't
in the volume
keep any parts of the mesh that are
inside of it
and clip any triangles that lie on the
boundary of the volume and lastly you
apply the texture by computing uv
coordinates based on where those
vertices are inside the volume
basically projecting those vertices into
the projector space to get texture
coordinates
and that's it you end up with an easy
and versatile technique to project
echoes and you can throw whatever shader
you want on them and they look great
the api is really straightforward you
only need to do a couple things and you
have yourself a nice little decal
let's take a look through the parameters
that you need to set this up so
basically you need to create a decal
geometry and that takes a few parameters
so the first parameter is mesh
this is the mesh that you're making the
deco from so essentially what surface
are you projecting your texture onto
then you have your position parameter
and position is the position of your
deco projector
typically you'd set this to the
intersection point of your array cast in
the mesh
orientation is a little bit
self-explanatory it's the orientation of
the decal projector
and you can use this to rotate your
decals randomly
and finally size again self-explanatory
it's how big your deco projector is let
me take a quick minute to point out that
i've been working on the shader course
for the past few months
so if you've ever wanted to learn
shaders starting small with colors and
textures and ramping up through a whole
bunch of more advanced topics like
lighting models noise sign distance
functions and more and using all of that
to build some cool projects like entire
scenes made entirely in shaders then
check out this course we're going to
start by just reusing the first person
camera code from our previous tutorial
and i'm quickly adding a spot where we
can try out our new decals
so i'm adding this update decals
function in the camera and we'll fire
this function off whenever someone
clicks the mouse so that's just checking
the input for mouse presses
so if not
disk.input.current.left button and
this.input.previous.left button
so the first part of this code
i need to create arraycaster
so that's what i'm doing here
i'm instantiating an instance of a
3.raycaster and we'll set that up from
the camera and the mouse position
now normally you might want to see where
in the screen the mouse is
but here we're just coding it to zero
zero as the position which is the dead
center of the screen
since that's where our targeting
reticule is
then we do a call on
raycaster.intersex objects and pass the
this dot scene objects
now you could also pass scene.children
to this like they do in the example code
but this lets me very specifically
control what objects we raycast against
and this list just happens to be just
the walls and the block in the middle
and it'll never change
if there are no hits return immediately
then we instantiate a new deco geometry
and we'll pass in parameters like the
mesh that we hit the position of the
deco
which is the intersection of the ray and
the geometry the rotation we need to
construct it out of the face as normal
because ideally we probably want to
apply the decal in the direction of the
normal
so that's all i'm doing here creating a
quick look at to look directly down the
normal at the face
then we need to create a material so i'm
instantiating a dummy mesh standard
material that's just set to white
and we should be good to go after that
then we create the decal itself by
creating a three dot mesh out of the
geometry and material so that's new
three dot mesh deco and deco material
i'll set it to receive shadows because
that looks better
and then we add it to the scene
once we do that we're all set i'm here
in my little world and when i press the
mouse button bam i get a decal
although you're seeing a slight problem
with this in that the decal is kind of
shimmering a little bit there's a bit of
zed fighting going on
luckily this has been solved before
shadow maps typically suffer from this
problem and it's an easy fix
you can use something like polygon
offset to create a variable depth offset
for the faces
this is a really basic feature in opengl
that has existed for ages
so we'll just make some small
modifications to deco material and we'll
add these new parameters we've got
polygon offset set to true
and then we'll set polygon offset factor
and we'll set it to some value and we'll
see how it goes
and once we're back in the demo we can
try applying a decal so i click the
mouse we get a decal and there's no zed
fighting so this is working
the last step here is that we can make
this look a little better by adding a
texture
and that's really simple i'm sure if
you've done 3.js before you know to use
a texture loader load up a decal
i've drawn one already
and i'll add that to the mesh standard
material as the map we'll set this to
transparent
and we're good to go
now that we're back in the demo i can
walk around and when i click the mouse
button we see a decal
and it looks great
i can walk around a bit more and pop off
a few more
and you can see that i've added a bit of
random rotation so as i shoot them off
they kind of rotate randomly so they're
not all just facing the exact same
direction
and i can get them on the walls and the
floors it works fine
now the technique isn't perfect
especially when using it dynamically in
a game situation rather than having
artists hand placed decals
they look great when you're projecting
somewhat parallel to the normal of the
surface like we're doing here these all
look good
but all it takes is you getting into a
little bit of a funky spot
like let's say i project a decal right
here right on the corner of this cube
close to the edge of the object
so the intersection point will be the
face facing me but it should wrap around
so the decal will have to wrap around
the side and what you end up with is
this streaking because this surface is
parallel to the direction of the decal
projection
so the texture is getting stretched out
and unfortunately there's no easy
solution here
most of these solutions are probably
going to revolve around trying to hide
the problem you can try fading out the
decal the further away it is from the
contact point or just limit the size of
your decals so these problems are hard
to see
it's not an easy problem to solve
but anyway this is a powerful little
feature that when integrated into your
game looks great and for relatively
little work
until next time cheers